in Washington DC and around the country
c-span is brought to you by your cable
or satellite provider
Washington Journal continues joining us
representative Al Green he represents
Houston he Democrat from Texas serves
the ninth district on our program good
morning to you morning it's the honor to
be with you you've come to light because
of your constant calls for the
impeachment of Donald Trump why do you
continue to make this case because it's
about our democracy and it's about our
Republic and it's about retaining it and
making sure that it's available not only
to us but to the future generations the
president has committed impeachable acts
the president's misdeeds are such that
they are deemed to be high misdemeanors
and as a result he can't be impeached I
might add this also the only difference
between my position and the position of
a good many of my colleagues is that I
want to do something about the misdeeds
and our good many of them want to just
talk about it
who are those that just want to talk
about it then and is that include Nancy
Pelosi and other leadership well what I
had allows this I allow the public to
make decisions about what others will do
and let others tell you what they'll do
but it's pretty clear that there are
good many other colleagues who question
the president's fitness to be in office
but they don't want to do very much
about it right now anyway my suspicion
is that as the momentum continues to
build we'll see more of them move over
to the side of wanting to see some
impeachment and if you listen to many of
the Talking Heads and persons on the
various talk shows they will talk about
everything but the word impeachment they
seem to contort themselves into a
position where they say the Senate will
have to do something the house may have
to do something but they won't say what
that something is there seems to be an
aversion to even uttering the word
impeachment but that's what the
Constitution provides that's what the
framers call for they had Donald Trump
in mind not by name not with the
specificities of who he is in this day
in time but they had a person such as
Trump in mind when they drafted article
2 section 4 of the Constitution such
that no person would be beyond justice
and this would include the present
the United States as far as those
offenses then what's a specific offense
that the president has done that
qualifies for impeachment a good many
let's start with just perfidy his his
dishonesty his ability to contort and
misconstrue that in and of itself can be
impeachable because of the harm that it
imposes upon society but the impeachment
articles that I brought before Congress
only twice by the way those articles
dealt with his invidious discrimination
his bigotry that is evidenced in his
policies when you have policies
emanating from the presidency that are
rooted in bigotry
then we should impeach that president
when the president talked about the
African countries and he used the s
whole word he was there discussing
immigration policy so that bigotry was
interwoven and integrated into that
policy which means that we have a right
as members of Congress to challenge that
we all not let that stand
barring Muslims from the country saying
there was some very fine people among
those in Charlottesville calling the
players professional players calling
their moms dogs when you use the term
sob then the B is a dog those kinds of
things are the kinds of bigotry that the
Constitution gives any member of
Congress to bring before the floor of
the house I am such a member I will
protect the Constitution and the people
a representative green our guest until
9:00 o'clock if you want to ask him
questions it's 2 o-two 7 4 8 8,000 for
democrats 202 seven for 8,000 one for
republicans independents 202 some four
eight eight thousand two and you compose
questions or comments on our twitter
feed it was President Trump in a rally
last month representative Greene that
talked about this idea of calls for his
impeachment what he thinks it might
result in I want to play his thoughts
and get your response to it
this November every American will face a
choice now they say if the house doesn't
make it very important you have great
congressmen these are great people these
are great great people and thank you but
we have to keep the house
because if you listen to Maxine Waters
she goes around saying we will impeach
him we will impeach him then people said
but he hasn't done anything wrong
oh that doesn't matter we will impeach
the president so I don't think we're
gonna have a lot of happy people if that
happens I think it's gonna be little bit
tough but she goes around and some
others we will impeach him does it
matter if you do anything right or wrong
they want to do that we got to win the
house and you know what we're gonna win
anyway
representin green on top of that it's
Nancy Pelosi herself says if Democrats
continue to talk about impeachment it's
a gift to Republicans particularly as
the midterms approach what do you think
well is not really about Republicans
it's about the Republic and it's not a
gift to Republicans this is a means of
maintaining the Republic that's what the
article two section four is all about so
I rather see it as an effort to make
sure that we protect the Constitution
and with reference to the president's
comments I don't know that he's read the
Federalist Papers but Federalist 65
Alexander Hamilton he talks about how
this is not going to be an easy process
he talks about there'll be a lot of
partisanship involved in the process he
talks about how this will be a tough
decision for a country to make but this
is the kind of thing that was
anticipated and I see this as our trying
out very best to let people understand
the process by the way when we started
there were people who thought that you
had to commit a crime you might remember
this and now people understand that you
don't have to commit a crime to be
impeached so rather than it being a gift
I see it as an opportunity a requirement
if you will a duty to do all that we can
to protect the Republic not a gift to
Republicans we have calls lined up to
you the first one is from Houston on our
Republican line this is Mike for
Representative Al Green Democrat of
Texas who serves Houston Mike good
morning go ahead good morning this
person is sitting at this deal right now
he is just he's not help Houston he's
not help Texas he's just a he's a liar
he me
to be voted on office along with Sheila
Jackson and Maxine Waters so I'd say
they're there they fabricate everything
that they talk about that's all they do
they steal from the Republican Party
they steal all the slogans everything
okay my mother talking at Mike do you
have a specific question for him yeah
well then he resigned we'll only let
somebody else younger run instead of him
just hanging in there and working
working the system that's all he does
okay representative Greene
well he's not alone with these opinions
there are good many people who have
opinions that are very strong and a good
many of them are threatening I've had to
alter a lot of my life because of people
who make threats and who for whatever
reasons choose to believe that free
speech is not available to me but it is
available to the president that the
president can make incendiary comments
and I can't respond to them that I
should just be quiet let the president
go on about his business of destroying
the norms in our society well I won't do
that
and to this gentleman and all of the
many others especially those who have
made their threatening comments I won't
be intimidated
I'm not going to alter I'm not going to
falter I'm going to stay the course and
if if the president continues with his
bigotry there will be additional
impeachment brought before the house
Detroit Michigan Democrats line Linda go
ahead yes I would like to know why the
Senate has not requested the president
shows taxes that is a federal offense if
I didn't show my taxes or if I didn't
file my taxes the government would be
looking for me
I also would like to know why why the
Democrat letting him get away with the
criminal things that he's doing like
paid to play and he's doing it more and
more each day it is not an
Vence for the president to withhold his
taxes I think that he should reveal them
I think that it it would give us some
insight into whether or not the
emoluments clause has been breached in
some way but it's not in advance and
with reference to actions taken by
others Democrats if you will members of
Congress I do think that we should do
more I am of the opinion that we should
have debates about the president's
behavior and those debates would be a
prelude to a vote up or down on articles
of impeachment which is why I have gone
so far as to bring articles of
impeachment twice and which is why I say
to people I will bring articles of
impeachment again the president
committed an impeachable act when he
fired the person who was investigating
him and went on national TV at prime
time and indicated that he did it
because of the investigation the Russian
thing as he called it well you can't
fire the person who's investigating you
you can do it in the sense of you have
the power but you cannot do it with
impunity you cannot do it without
repercussions the president knows that
he committed an impeachable Act which is
why he continues with all of these
distractions which is why he tries to
misdirect and cause us to do anything
but investigate properly his actions but
I see in mr. Muller an opportunity for
an investigation to take place but I
don't see that there is likely to be a
recommendation from him that we impeach
he is investigating criminality in a
sense he's on the judicial side of this
he's he's trying to investigate
something that might go before a court
at some point but he's not going to say
we should impeach that won't be his
recommendation that then requires that
Congress to do something if there are
impeachable acts made by virtue of what
the report connotes I don't know what
he'll say but I can tell you this the
public is very much aware of this
behavior this insidious invidious
behavior and the public wants to see
some action from Congress representative
green if Democrats take back the house
in November what is the likelihood that
Speaker Nancy Pelosi will bring up an
impeachment charge I'll let Speaker
Pelosi address her actions but here is a
point that I think is salient and one
that ought to be referenced every member
of the House is accorded the opportunity
to bring up impeachment this is not
something that the Constitution has
bestowed upon leadership it's something
that every member has a right and
privilege of doing so I'm not sure that
there'll be members who are going to
wait for someone else if that's someone
else doesn't matter who it is is
declining to do it we can all do it and
I think that there's a good likelihood
that there will be articles of
impeachment wait
have you heard directly from the
Minority Leader about these efforts of
yours specifically to asking you to stop
asking you to hold back anything along
that line well I don't think you you
have to ask me what I've heard I think
it's probably if you've read
publications it's intuitively obvious to
perhaps even the most casual observer
that she and I are in different places
on this and I respect her position I
have great respect for this the speaker
and I still refer to her as a speaker
once the speaker always a speaker I was
a great respect for her I trust that she
has a level of respect for me such that
she understands that I will do what my
conscience dictates as I expect that she
will as well from our Republican line in
Florida Brian for Representative Al
Green come on II represent green like I
like to ask you and and over the time of
our all from day one has there been a
time when a president should have been
impeached well I can tell you that
Andrew Johnson was impeached and as was
the case with President Clinton they
were not convicted in the Senate but
they were impeached and my suspicion is
that we've had a good many federal
judges as a matter of fact federal
judges have been impeached and convicted
so yes there have been times and the
record shows that there have been
persons who would not only impeached
also convicted in the senator from
Virginia Vienna Virginia Democrats line
Oscar yes good morning gentlemen
the Glenn's are just high like hi I
wanted to just highlight how it is
important to understand President Trump
is performing foreign policy but his
conduct is still unbecoming a present
his conduct as you mentioned with the
illegal ban the Muslim ban so-called
Muslim Bank we have to remind everyone
Bill Clinton was in peach but he was
acquitted in the Senate because his
actions did not involve the Congress it
was a personal issue and with Donald
Trump his actions do involve legislative
and judiciary violations while in office
and I would like you to explain that and
and I want to ask does any member of the
freedom caucus represent your push for
impeachment I do I really believe god
Carla Thanks
in summary the president is unfit for
the job he's unfit to be President and
again a good many of my colleagues agree
with me the difference between my
position and theirs is I want to do
something about it I don't know how we
can conclude that the president is unfit
that he engages in perfidy that he would
do dastardly things by and through his
policy but don't then say let's do
something about that
I just cannot allow myself to sit and
see what's happening to my country
Eugene Robinson has a column today
wherein he talks about the misdeeds of
the president and he uses the term a
gutless Congress that's not my term
that's his but I do think that at some
point Congress has to focus on these
actions and take some additional action
but for me it won't matter what
I get a majority of the members of the
House to vote one way or another whether
there will be a second vote what is
important for me is that my record will
show that I did all that I could maybe I
couldn't do enough but I at least did
all that I could to protect liberty and
justice for all
I asked you about what you heard from
Democratic Legion what have you heard
from Republicans on your efforts I have
actually had and when you say what I'm
about to say people who wonder who was
it and when that was it said but I've
actually had a Republican member who
said you know I'm strongly considering
impeachment now and I can only say to
you that my suspicion is that there are
good many others who believe that we've
reached that point in our history but
it's a difficult bridge for some to
cross for me it is really not about the
difficulty as much as it is about the
necessity to do something about an unfit
president this is Bill and Bill is from
Missouri Republican line for our guest
representative Al Green
yeah congressman I'm enjoying that
listening to you let me just say that I
live in a racially gerrymandered
Democratic district turn Missouri so I
can appreciate what you're saying a
little bit from a different perspective
but one of the thoughts that I have is
is I think Donald Trump would relish an
impeachment by you I think that he would
think that would be the greatest show on
earth and constitutionally it would be
and I think that he thinks he could
probably beat you I wonder if you've
thought about what he really thinks
about the issue of impeachment thank you
well thank you very much I have not put
a lot of time into thinking about his
thoughts on the issue what I've tried to
do is look at it from the perspective of
a member of Congress who understands
what article 2 section 4 is about who
understands the Federalist Papers read
Hamilton Madison understand that George
Mason was the person who pushed in a
very specific way for us to make sure
that the president wasn't beyond justice
so understanding these things
I focused primarily on what I must do as
a member of Congress and by the way I've
not insisted that anyone do anything
other than what they would do what their
conscience dictates but what I have said
is this my conscience dictates that I do
something so please don't don't do what
you would not do if you thought your
conscience dictated it give me the
opportunity to pursue this to pursue
what I perceive as harm being done to
our society and a good many people agree
with me they are good many however don't
want to take the steps necessary to do
something about it now on the other hand
a good many do agree and take steps to
do something about it because we did
have 66 members of Congress to vote for
impeachment 30 of them if Democrats were
in charge of the house would be
chairpersons of full committees or
subcommittees so we have people who
believe that this is appropriate and who
want to do something about it I think
that the momentum has to build for this
I believe that
when Rosa Parks took that seat on the
bus she didn't think she was going to
end all discrimination that evening if
since a matter of fact was still
fighting invidious discrimination but
she knew that that was a step that had
to be taken and I know that what we've
done were steps that had to be taken but
there are additional steps that must be
taken
what body and Congress has to determine
impeachment and what's the threshold so
determine if impeachable offense has
been done the house has that
jurisdiction it is exclusively the
province of the House of Representatives
this is where the bar of justice is and
the president of the United States if he
is impeached in the house then it goes
to the Senate which will have a trial
presided over by the Chief Justice of
the Supreme Court and then if the Senate
convicts the president then the
president would be removed from office
which is what is likely to happen if
Muller gives a report that is strong
such to the extent that Republicans will
start to defect then it's likely to
happen
but I don't concern myself as much with
the likelihood as I do with the fact
that the offense has been committed a
good many people are prosecuted in this
country for offenses that they have
committed and they don't get to tell the
prosecutor you should not investigate me
they don't get to defame and demean the
prosecution to the extent that the
president goes about defaming and
demeaning his own justice department I
think that my duty is to bring the case
and let the jury then decide which will
be the House of Representatives this is
Bob cooks filled Tennessee Republican
mine good morning thank you practical
cost congressman green I'd like to ask
you a couple questions would you care to
state right now what your net worth was
before you took office and what it is
right now and exactly what have you done
for your own constituents besides being
a race Baker
well my net worth is something that has
been made public I quite frankly don't
count my money the same way those who've
made it public count it
but the research is there and available
for you to do and now with reference to
my being a race baiter I think that
you're entitled to your opinion and I
respect the right that the Constitution
has accorded you to have that opinion
and my trust is that you'll respect my
right to have my opinion based on facts
not based upon suspicions and some sort
of visceral reaction because of my
disdain for a person my my belief is
that the president's behavior is what we
must talk about and that behavior is
evidence of his bigotry which has
penetrated his policies which impact all
of us in this country even you my dear
friend they do in Toms River New Jersey
Kevon independent line yeah hello thank
you c-span representative screen a
number of questions first of all there's
the lowest black unemployment in modern
history
secondly
Trump donated a million dollars after
the hurricane I wonder how much you
donated you know donating to Houston and
thirdly 40% of the country is backing
him you don't feel that you would be
slapping them in the face for their vote
thank you I would never slap the
president in any way I think you mean of
course figuratively not literally I am I
always refer to mr. Trump as a president
I respect the fact that he was elected
but this does not negate the fact that
when his behavior is harmful to society
the framers of the Constitution provided
a remedy for his behavior and that
remedy is impeachment for misdeeds
misdemeanors as is indicated in article
2 section 4 really refers to misdeeds so
I don't concern myself with the fact
that 40% would support him quite frankly
if he had the support of 90% of the
people and behaved this way my position
would still be the same
you just don't allow this kind of
behavior to go unchallenged and if the
truth be told the people who would judge
our behavior many of them hasn't been
born yet that will properly judge what's
going on because many of us are blinded
by the circumstances that we have to
exist in on a daily basis with friends
and social pressure
I have extricated myself from these
things I consider myself a liberated
Democrat I'm liberated to the extent
that I can not only speak truth to power
I can speak truth about power and I'm
going to be as truthful as I can be to
make sure that people understand that
it's not about the man is about the
country that is not about Democrats it's
about democracy that is not about
Republicans it's about the Republic that
is about liberty and justice for all
that's what I stand for and I'm not
going to tolerate a president who has
bigotry integrated into his policies
clay
in Indiana Democrats line I have a cook
I have a question for you and you're
talking about behavior of presidents
years talking about impeaching Trump
over some minor stuff but you didn't
stand up and say anything about when
Obama committed treason by knowingly
getting weapons sizes four different
times I want to know your opinion on
that part well they're 435 members of
Congress don't really recall anybody
bringing articles of impeachment each
member has the opportunity to do so so
if others thought that this was the case
then they could have brought articles of
impeachment they chose not to for
whatever reasons I don't agree with your
contentions so that's why I have not
acted on those those statements that you
made feels truthful apologies after the
shooting in Santa Fe yes
barring any significant action happening
in Congress what's the best way forward
in dealing with these school shootings
well the best way forward is for
significant action to take place in
Congress we should not only debate these
things in the public arena
we should also debate them on the floor
of the House of Representatives we
should debate but then we should
legislate it's time for us to vote we
need to know where every person stands
on these various issues example the
notion that the solution is a good guy
with a gun the solution to a bad guy
with a gun is a good guy with a gun well
let's have some legislation that says
that and let's let every member of
Congress vote as to whether or not this
is the solution a good guy with a gun I
think that we need more background
checks we need to vote on that I think
that we need to make sure that we close
what's called the gun show loophole we
need to vote on that I think that guns
ought to be safely locked away so that
children can access them this is
something to be voted on I do think that
there's more that we can do to secure
our schools but I know that money has to
be appropriated for it that Congress can
appropriate the money if we can give
hundreds of billion dollars to
corporations in rebates and tax breaks
then we can appropriate funds to
properly have our schools secured the
is the kind of thing that Congress can
do but you can't do it without voting
tough talk is great tough votes are
better we've got to take some of these
tough votes and final comment on it is
this the Speaker of the House is the
impediment we have a speaker who has
said he is not going to run again we
have a speaker who for whatever reasons
won't bring legislation to the floor we
have over a hundred pieces of
legislation some of it I don't agree
with but I think we ought to vote on it
on the floor of the House of
Representatives this is a time for us to
put aside the partisanship and give
every member the opportunity to vote on
these hundred plus pieces of legislation
and if the speaker is not going to do
that if he's not going to let us vote
then the speaker ought to step aside
he's already said that he won't run
again there's a speaker just step aside
and let us take the votes this is what
the country expect expects of us we were
elected to vote we are a part of the
representative form of government in
fact seat of that representative form of
government we are the representatives
how can the views of my constituents be
known if we don't vote let us vote and
mr. speaker this is your duty your
responsibility and your obligation susan
is next in Goodyear Arizona Republican
line excuse my voice but I've been sick
with the flu you know I've heard you on
the floor I just want to pray for you
and the Democrats and the Republicans
you all need to get along for the United
States every time you guys go on the
floor all I hear is negative negative
then with the schools our school got
shot here in Avondale and good year five
six years ago so what we did was we put
the detectors in we had a door coming in
and the door go on out and it had no
problems ever since Doug Ducey did that
we voted for it it was awesome now we
have no problems the kids could drive
the car in and dry the car out one way
in one way out
same thing walking in and walking out
gotcha Susan thank you thank you running
out of time well I appreciate the
prayers but a good many people have
reached a point where prayers are not
enough for them they want to see us take
action we were elected to take action
that action is to debate but to vote so
I think that is our obligation to
protect all of society by having these
hundred plus bills come to vote before
the house and let's vote on them and
make decisions about how our children
are going to be protected children are
being murdered at school parents are
sending their children to school weary
of whether or not they will come home
safely and we can do something about
this but we can't do it by just talking
about it by just meeting we have to take
votes and pass legislation I thank you
for the time
representative Al Green Democrat from
Texas who serves the city of Houston
thank you thank you coming up we're
going to hear from actor Eric Bergen and
vh1 Save the Music Foundation Henry
Donahue about a conversation on federal
funding for arts programs later on on
the program we'll look to some of the
primary contests taking place across the
country and more of your phone calls
those coming up on Washington Journal
[Music]